shipshape ship hi guys hi bubbles hi
walter hi dolly hey mama hi baby hi alby
one two three
jenny's farm didn't start out with
animals that were missing limbs they
just happened to come to her farm
and she felt well prosthetic technology
has helped me it could certainly help
them
i can't imagine not having an artificial
leg because i lost my leg at 10 and i'm
quite used to it it's thanks to medical
science that i'm able to live this
normal life and for these animals i want
no different for them hi felix what goes
on at woodstock farm sanctuary on a
daily basis we're home to right now
around 300 rescued farm animals they've
all come from bad places and they get
the veterinary care the health care that
they need on a daily basis
she's feisty
can you come help me with felix they're
all actually in the front pasture
little felix came to us as a as a baby
lamb and he had come from a big sheep
farm and overnight some sort of predator
had gotten in and they found little
felix with
um his leg chewed off and so i spoke to
my prosthetist the gentleman who makes
my legs eric
i don't know if many clinicians would
have went out to the farm i don't have
any experience with fitting prosthetics
on animals very few people in the
country do
so i figured if i could take what
knowledge that i do have and apply it to
the animal i could probably get them to
utilize a prosthesis
and it wasn't until we got hooked up
with suny new pulse and their 3d
printing lab that we were able to make
something pretty cool and cutting edge
for him
seeing him walk on the leg was
absolutely amazing from my limited
interactions with him he isn't
necessarily the most outgoing sheep in
the world was actually very sheepish but
what he ended up doing was he started
running away from us which was amazing
we were just jumping for joy that he
could actually get up and run keep up
with his flock
he looked like he was a very happy sheep
if we could do this more
on other animals we wouldn't have to you
know put them down most of the world
doesn't fully understand it they think
of them as just farmed animals but we
hope that that changes
and that's part of the magic of what we
do here they get
pastures to roam in access to the sun
and to the grass
they live life the way they were
intended to live
there's no greater joy
you